Okay, so what were you doing at this moment I came by?
Not stalking you.
What did you find yourself doing a lot these days?
Playing Heads Up.
What's your current obsession?
Heads Up.
Can you make any prediction...
...about anything exactly one year from now?
I think I'll be doing a lot of traveling.
Besides doing adventurous interviews like this,...
...what do you do on your days off?
Hang out with my friends.
Where's your favorite place to visit in the world?
Europe.
What specific thing do you love the most about Texas?
The people.
What's the most enjoyable activity when you're home in Texas?
Eating my Nana's food.
What's something you own that you truly cherish?
My jewelry.
What's the one thing you can never live without?
My family.
Out of all the hobbies in the world,...
...what's one hobby that you'll never give up?
Dancing.
What's one hobby that you plan on picking up?
Learning new languages.
What's something you'd like to say to your 112 million Instagram followers?
I get to do what I love every single day and it's because of you.
Thank you.